herzlich willkommen das ist zdf heute
live wer in deutschland in einem corona
hotspot lebt und in deutschland urlaub
machen will der kann das in zukunft
nicht mehr es sei denn er hat einen
negativen corona test vorzuweisen
darauf so wollten wir eigentlich sagen
haben sich im groben heute die
staatskanzleichefs in einer schalte
geeinigt aber wenn wir jetzt aktuell auf
die meldungen gucken dann sehen wir von
wegen einheitlichkeit gerade meldet zum
beispiel die dpa thüringen trägt ein
beherbergungs verbot so nicht mit und
auch die dpa meldet aus nordrhein
westfalen
es gibt keinen automatismus zunächst
kein beherbergungs verbot in nordrhein
westfalen also wieder nichts mit
einheitlichkeit wir sprechen darüber
heute abend mit ihnen und mit dem arzt
und medizinjournalisten doktor christoph
specht einen schönen guten abend nach
düsseldorf für die user gilt wie immer
eure fragen in die kommentare und wenn
ihr uns über die zdf heute app guckt
dann könnt ihr eure fragen auch an diese
genau an diese adresse schicken
herr doktor specht und auch liebe user
ich würde gerne zum einstieg einen blick
auf die deutschlandkarte werfen die uns
zeigt was denn überhaupt im moment die
risikogebiete sind und wir sehen hier
die aktuellen neuinfektionen aufbereitet
von zdf heute wir sehen überall da wo es
dunkelblau ist wird diese grenze von 50
einwohnern pro 100.000 einwohner 50
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner
gerissen
das ist zb in berlin der fall
das ist seit kurzem auch in bremen der
fall seit kurzem auch in esslingen ein
landkreis in baden württemberg und
andere hotspot die schon seit einigen
tagen
diese grenze überschreiten herr doktor
specht aus ihrer sicht für wii
sinnvoll halten sie einen beherbergungs
verbot das einheitlich innerhalb von
ganz deutschland gelten würde also wie
sagte schon das beste daran wäre
tatsächlich die einheitlichkeit aber ich
habe große zweifel ob das der richtige
weg ist denn die bevölkerung verliert
vor allen dingen wenn es so
durcheinander geht dann langsam den
glauben an diejenigen die jetzt alles in
der hand haben und solche regeln und
maßnahmen aufstellen und wenn große
teile der bevölkerung nicht mehr mit
geht dann haben wir genau das gegenteil
erreicht denn das virus ist ja durchaus
da und man muss auch vorsichtig sein
aber wenn die bevölkerung nicht mehr
hinter diesen massnahmen steht zum teil
auch deswegen weil sie einfach nicht
mehr nachvollziehen kann
dann haben wir nichts gewonnen sondern
ganz im gegenteil viel verloren
das heißt aber wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe dann wurde damit etwas verloren
heute denn der versuch einheitlichkeit
in dieser frage herzustellen der ist ja
ganz offensichtlich wenn man sich die
aktuelle entwicklung anschaut
gescheitert das sieht ganz so aus ja
diese alleingänge werden von der
bevölkerung nicht wirklich gut
angenommen weil das bedeutet dass zur
folge man muss wenn man sich bewegen
möchte erstmal im internet nachgucken in
den nachrichten schauen überall in den
landkreisen schauen gehörig denn jetzt
eigentlich auch schon zu einem
risikogebiet wie wird das überhaupt
definiert und sie hat uns ja gesagt mit
den 50 neuinfektionen pro 100000 wenn
wir ehrlich sind aus medizinisch
epidemiologischer sicht ist das ein
bisschen gewürfelt ich verstehe dass
politik natürlich genaue grenzen angeben
muss man kann es da auch nicht beliebig
machen aber es gibt jetzt nicht den
medizinischen hintergrund dass man sagen
kann bei 50 ist es tatsächlich kritisch
und bei 49 noch nicht das ist ja nicht
der fall und das merkt natürlich auch
bemerken große teile der bevölkerung und
da sehe ich eine große gefahr darin wenn
man sie nicht mitnehmen kann
inwiefern da vielleicht noch andere
kriterien eine rolle spielen sollten bei
der einschätzung der lage und bei der
frage ab wann ist was wo ein
risikogebiet
da kommen wir später im verlauf der
sendung noch drauf langsam kommen hier
die ersten user meinungen
jean joseph mouret zum beispiel schreibt
über facebook nichts
nur noch mehr spaltung es reicht also da
sieht man schon die reaktionen auf diese
nach wie vor nicht einheitlichen regeln
die sind ziemlich klar ich würde gerne
einmal einen blick darauf werfen was
denn so heute im gespräch war und auch
wie sich die aktuellen infektionszahlen
in ganz bestimmten risikogebieten heute
entwickelt haben das würde ich zwar
gerne tun aber daran dass herr beitrag
nicht kommt stelle ich fest dass der
beitrag noch nicht da ist dann stellen
wir das hinten an und nutzen die zeit
direkt darüber zu sprechen was wären
denn für sie kriterien die man anlegen
müsste um zu sagen in der gemengelage
aus diesen und diesen kriterien ist das
ein risikogebiet welche faktoren würden
sie da anlegen also einig sind wir uns
sicher auch mit all denen die diese
regeln aufstellen müssen es ist sehr
kompliziert und nicht so fest zu machen
aber wenn wir mal an einen kreis schauen
vechta zum beispiel gehört seit einigen
tagen dazu da gab es einen ausbruch in
einem altenheim das wird jetzt zunehmen
in krankenhäusern sehen wir immer
häufiger solche fälle eine große anzahl
dem relativ kleinen ort kann das
natürlich einen mächtigen ausschlag
geben und fragen sich natürlich alle
leute die drum herum wurden irgendwo in
vechta warum sie denn jetzt zu diesem
kreis gehören bauen sie jetzt
infektiöser sein sollen als vielleicht
jemand anderes in einem der großstadt
bereich ich denke dass wir insgesamt
auch davon wegkommen müssen immer nur
den blick auf die neuinfektionen zu
haben die täglichen neuinfektionen das
war richtig am anfang der pandemie da
hatten wir auch nichts anderes an den
zahlen mittlerweile müssten wir dazu
übergehen andere parameter mit
hineinzunehmen also immer auch die
wichtige zahl die häufig schon erwähnt
wurde in anderen kontext nämlich die
stationär stationären patienten ein
frühwarnsystem um zu sehen wie
entwickelt sie ist denn da das sind die
entscheidenden parameter und da gibt es
natürlich das gegenargument dass man
sagt na ja das hängt ja immer den
infektionen sehr hinterher das heißt die
infektion die wir jetzt sehen das sind
ja auch die testergebnisse
das sind infektionen die schon vor
einigen tagen stattgefunden haben und
wenn dann
die ist derzeit etwa 15 prozent
hospitalisiert also ins krankenhaus
kommen müssen von allen infizierten dann
ist das ja noch mal nach klappt aber ich
glaube wenn man diese zahlen
kontinuierlich erfasst und sie werden ja
erfasst aber auch nennt dann kann man
auch da sehen wo die reise hingeht das
hielte ich für besser als immer nur auf
die neuinfektionen zu schielen
nun gibt es verschiedene user meinungen
vor allem viele fragen eine davon ist
zum beispiel barbara wiesler die über
facebook fragt muss ich mich als gast
wird selber darum kümmern wer bei mir
übernachten darf nun sind sie arzt und
können natürlich auch nicht erklären was
sich die politiker da ausgedacht haben
aber wenn man das richtig versteht dann
ist das so ja genau darauf würde es
letztendlich hinauslaufen das haben wir
auch in anderen bereichen gesehen dass
man gastwirte vornehmlich gastwirte so
zu hilfs beamten der staatsanwaltschaft
machte er als hilfssheriffs herumlaufen
lässt wir bei dem erfassen der namen in
der gastronomie haben wir ja schon
gelernt dass hatte das natürlich nicht
rechtens ist der gastronom darf sich
also nicht hinstellen und sagen ich
möchte jetzt mal ihren ausweis sehen ob
sie auch wirklich der hermann müller
sind den sie hier im namen eingetragen
haben und so ähnlich ist es natürlich
jetzt auch bei der beherbergung wer soll
das kontrollieren das ist ja die große
frage
und wenn man das abwälzt auf gastronomen
die an sich selber eigentlich eher daran
interessiert werden auch ein geschäft zu
machen nämlich ihr beherbergungsgewerbe
nachzugehen
dann sehe ich das alles wirklich
falschen weg es gibt weitere kommentare
zum thema föderalismus sandra bei
schreibt über facebook verdammt nochmal
förderalismus schön und gut hier ist
aber eine bundeseinheitliche lösung
extrem wichtig alles andere irritiert
die menschen und fördert nur
unverständnis und ablehnung silke
gänzlich schreibt auf facebook so ein
durcheinander und das innerhalb
deutschlands und hans erich kästner
kirchgässner schreibt auch über facebook
sind denn diese landesregierung nur noch
bekloppt ist das das ergebnis unseres
föderalismus darauf können wir locker
verzichten
was würden sie denn als arzt dazu sagen
sie können ganz bestimmt auch verstehen
dass die leute sich über unheil
etliche regeln aufregen würden sie sagen
trotzdem ist es ein gewinn dass wir
diesen föderalismus haben weil wir eben
in der lage sind ganz speziell auf
infektionsgeschehen einzugehen und zu
reagieren ohne dass eben viele andere
betroffen sind die eigentlich gar nicht
betroffen sein müssten
der föderalismus ganz genau hat viele
vorteile dass man eben lokal agieren
kann gerade bei so einer pandemie halte
ich das für wichtig aber was wir jetzt
ja momentan haben sind ja noch nicht
einmal allgemeingültige regel die regeln
sollten schon überall gelten und dann
heißt es eben da haben wir das erreicht
haben was nicht erreichen müssen was
aber auch gleichmäßig umsetzen
ich bin bei ihm zweifel ob das jetzt
gerade bei diesen infektionszahlen
wirklich so machbar ist auf dauer dann
stellen sie sich vor wir können die
situation haben dass immer mehr kreise
diese 30 35 vielleicht auch 50
neuinfektionen die inzidenz auf sieben
tage pro 100000 einwohner gerechnet
reißen und dann darf quasi keine jetzt
von da nach dort fahren gut das ist ja
nicht für private reisen momentan
gemeint sondern es sind dies das
beherbergungsgewerbe gemeint sofern will
man das einfach runter drücken auch
sicher mit blick auf die herbstferien
aber ich glaube dass das für die zukunft
nicht praktikabel sein wird wir haben
immer gesagt auch in den vergangenen
monaten kann man sagen dass zum herbst
und zum winter die infektionszahlen
steigen werden das sehen wir jetzt was
wir glaube ich auch nicht wirklich
verhindern können aber was wir
vielleicht verhindern können ist dass
diese infektion wieder dort eintritt wo
die menschen besonders gefährdet sind
das sind eben die wohlhabenden gruppen
wie es so schön heißt also die
verletzlichen spricht die alten und die
chronisch kranken da müssten wir aus
meiner sicht den fokus darauf legen dass
wir diese menschen schützen aber auch so
dass sie noch eine menschenwürde haben
also auch noch besuch bekommen können da
werden neue testen rolle spielen aber
wenn wir einfach das leben sozusagen
jetzt nicht mehr als general lockdown
sondern als überall lockt dauern aber im
kleinteiligen machen dann werden wir uns
glaube ich damit keinen gefallen tun
weil sie das gerade angesprochen haben
mit den privaten reisen würde ich gerne
eine frage noch einschieben und zwar von
vanille auch über facebook darf ich zu
freunden
bayern reisen wenn ich aus einem
risikogebiet komme sie haben das zwar
gerade schon angeschnitten aber könnten
sie darauf nochmal ein bisschen eingehen
also man muss man sehr vorsichtig sein
weil es ändert sich ja alles so schnell
bei einem privaten reisen scheint es
stand jetzt so noch möglich zu sein wenn
das eben keine beherbergung in einem
hotel in einem gaststätte pension oder
was auch immer ist aber wer weiß man
muss vorsichtig sein das kann sich alles
relativ schnell ändern
mir scheint es so zu sein dass man jetzt
mit diesen beschlüssen hauptsächlich die
reisezeit die bevorstehende herbstreise
zeit wieder im auge hatte und hier quasi
ein dämpfer rhein geben wollte dass die
leute möglichst nicht viel reißen dann
schauen wir uns mal an wie die lage denn
im moment in deutschland ist und wie
gesagt in welchen gebieten die lage aus
welchen gründen auch gerade besonders
angespannt ist
und wieder hat es einen schlachthof
erwischt wieder in niedersachsen in
diesem betrieb haben sich mindestens 63
mitarbeiter mit dem krone virus
infiziert damit drohen dem landkreis
cloppenburg erneut schärfere maßnahmen
auch die stadt bremen hat erstmals die
grenze von 50 neuinfektionen auf 100000
einwohner innerhalb von sieben tagen
überschritten
damit gelten in der hansestadt
automatisch schärfere regeln unter
anderem für freizeitparks private feiern
und großveranstaltungen
das virus ist weiter auf dem vormarsch
die bundesregierung alarmiert wir haben
sprunghaft ansteigende zahlen
insbesondere in einigen deutschen
großstädten auch in der hauptstadt die
eben nicht mehr einem einzelnen
ausbruchsgeschehen zuzuordnen sind
sondern die befürchten lassen dass es zu
einer weiteren diffusen verbreitung des
virus kommen kann
pünktlich zu den herbstferien ist auch
innerdeutsche reisen kompliziert
geworden weil die bundesländer ganz
unterschiedlich mit deutschen krone
risikogebieten umgehen
das soll sich jetzt aber ändern heute
wurde ein bundesweites beherbergungs
verbot für urlauber aus inländischen
krone risikogebieten beschlossen
wer beispielsweise aus berlin mitte
kommt und keinen negativen test vorlegen
kann darf dann in münchen nicht mehr
übernachten in vielen bundesländern
gelten immer noch unterschiedliche
maßnahmen das kann ziemlich verwirrend
sein bin jetzt dienstlicher schleswig
holstein unterwegs und wofür wir das
heute nachdoppeln kann in kiel
aber ich denke mal da muss bald
einheitliches her einen flickenteppich
gibt es weiter bei der quarantäne einige
bundesländer wie rheinland-pfalz
schreiben eine quarantäne pflicht für
rückkehrer aus in der deutschen
risikogebieten vor die nur dann nicht
gilt wenn rückkehrer ein negatives
testergebnis vorlegen können oder
weniger als 72 stunden im risikogebiet
waren oder es trifft die reise gründe
gibt wie sorgerecht oder medizinische
behandlung es bleibt also kompliziert
und unübersichtlich
tja und dazu kommt dass dieses gerade
genannte bundesweite beherbergungs
verbot ganz offensichtlich auch gar
nicht mehr bundesweit gilt mehrere
stunden nachdem es eigentlich so
öffentlich verkündet worden war
herr doktor specht die frage stellt sich
ja nicht nur was die privaten
urlaubsreisen an geht jetzt zur
ferienzeit sondern auch gerade
angesprochen haben zwei pendler gesehen
oder berufs reisende gerd sinne welt
fragt über facebook sinn welt meine güte
fragt über facebook darf man
geschäftlich beruflich reisen und
übernachten
eigentlich müssten sie als mediziner
doch jetzt sagen ob die person aus
privaten gründen im hotel übernachtet
oder aus beruflichen ist dem virus
eigentlich egal
genauso ist es auch selbstverständlich
sind völlig egal
es gibt diese regelung und diese diese
schwierigkeit diese regelungen überhaupt
zu machen natürlich überall in der
grenzregion zb aachen zu belgien rüber
war es ja auch so dass sie dort zwar
geschäftlich pendeln konnten da gab es
eine ausnahmegenehmigung wenn sie dann
aber 30 minuten da drüben waren nur um
was einzukaufen dann mussten sie
eigentlich beim zurückreisen schon
wieder 14 tage in quarantäne
es macht natürlich keinen sinn das hat
man inzwischen gekippt dann hat gesagt
ja wenn das nur soundsoviel stunden war
dann ist das auch in dieser regelung wir
drin aber daran sieht man schon hier
prallen zwei dinge aufeinander auf der
einen seite die virologie die
epidemiologie die reine medizin und auf
der anderen seite die praktikabilität
und da kneift es an allen ecken und
enden als ich den beitrag eben gerade
der kommentator versuchte die
verschiedenen regelungen darzulegen
fühlte ich mich wirklich an loriot
erinnert das ist ja sketch reif und ich
denke man muss wirklich aufpassen dass
man die bevölkerung jetzt hier nicht so
sauer macht mit dem ganzen durcheinander
dass das was wirklich wichtig ist
nämlich maske tragen abstand halten dann
auch noch auf der strecke bleibt
es gibt die möglichkeit die italien
jetzt gerade beschlossen hat zusagen im
ganzen land gilt eine masken pflicht
egal wo wenn man vom haus auf die straße
geht muss man die maske tragen
das ist auch eine frage die uns über
facebook erreicht von ns hildering wie
sinnvoll sind masken in öffentlich
genutzten straßen das wäre eine klare
regel dass wäre bundesweit dann ebenso
zu machen für wie sinnvoll hielten sie
eine solche maßnahme hier in deutschland
es gibt unterschiedliche ansichten dazu
meine ansicht dazu ist im freien macht
das keinen sinn klar es kann ausnahmen
geben dann wenn der abstand überhaupt
nicht eingehalten wird und ganz viele
menschen auf engem raum auch draußen aus
unter freiem himmel zusammen kommen dann
ist natürlich eine maske oder wenn alle
eine maske tragen besser als wir das
nicht geschieht aber wenn wir eine ganz
normale situation auf einem platz auf
einem gehweg wo auch immer uns
vorstellen wo in lockerem abstand
menschen sich aufhalten oder einfach nur
gehen aufeinander vorbeigehen sehe ich
tatsächlich dafür aus medizinischer
biologischer sicht keinen sinn wir haben
andere stellen wo sich die leute
anstecken und da müssen wir hingucken
das ist auch nicht beim supermarkt wenn
die leute dort fünf minuten zehn minuten
einkaufen und nicht sich lange dort
aufhalten sondern es ist eindeutig bei
den privaten feiern wo dann ein
psychologischer aspekt nämlich zum
tragen kommt hier kommt die tante erna
aus münchen mit onkel j aus hamburg
zusammen
man sagt sich na ja wir sind ja familie
und natürlich fällt dann die maske im
wahrsten sinne des wortes die zittern da
keine auf aber onkel lebt halt in
hamburg und das ist das problem wir sind
ja nicht mehr im gleichen haushalt wenn
wir darauf den fokus legen würden dann
bräuchten wir uns mit solchen die ich
finde pseudo regelung und ob soldo
sicherheitsregelungen mit masken im
freien nicht aufhalten
und das alles eben vor dem hintergrund
dass die zahlen wie der
regierungssprecher ist eben gesagt hat
in die höhe schnellen wir schauen uns
mal die entwicklung der zahlen aktuell
an
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich in deutschland täglich 2380
menschen infiziert gestern lag dieser
wert noch bei 2290 ein vergleichsweise
deutliche anstieg ein blick auf die
vergangenen monate zeigt nach dem
höhepunkt anfang april mit
durchschnittlich fast 6000 neu
infizierten täglich viel die kurve im
sommer steil ab und steigt jetzt langsam
aber sicher wieder an
ist das eine entwicklung die ihnen
sorgen macht also diese infektionszahlen
von märz april und infektionszahlen oder
neuinfektionen zahlen von jetzt kann man
nicht miteinander vergleichen
der grund ist ganz simpel es sind ja
auch nicht wenn man es ganz genau nimmt
infektionszahlen sondern sind die zahlen
positiver tests wir haben im märz april
überhaupt nicht die tests kapazitäten
gehabt die wir jetzt haben seit einiger
zeit werden etwa 900.000 pcr test in der
woche gemacht in deutschland das ist
sensationell viel dh die 6b 2800 von
heute kann man nicht mit 2800 im märz
vergleichen trotzdem natürlich die
zahlen steigen die neuinfektionen
steigen wie gesagt vor monaten war schon
klar dass zum herzen zum winter hin
genau das geschehen wird ich bin auch
sicher dass wir das nicht wirklich
verhindern können und zwar deshalb weil
das virus hoch infektiös ist hoch
infektiös heißt nicht hoch krankmachend
es ist krank machend aber da gibt es
viren die sind noch wesentlich krank
machen trotzdem sterben einige leute und
auf der anderen seite aber haben wir das
ohr gerade mal wieder zurecht setzen
auf der anderen seite sind diese
infektionszahlen zunächst einmal
erschreckend wir müssen aber schauen wen
es trifft wenn es ältere trifft
chronisch kranke
dann ist das genau die gruppe wo dann
auch wieder die todeszahlen steigen
werden das müssen wir versuchen zu
verhindern
ich möchte gerne auch weil sie das
anfang des gesprächs gesagt haben das
gespräch damit quasi beenden mit der
gefahr droht dass auch menschen die
dieses virus ernst nehmen die sagen es
ist gefährlich
ich sehe es sterben menschen es kann
auch jüngere leute stark gefährden es
gibt spätfolgen wir müssen dieses virus
ernst nehmen ich halte nicht an die
regeln die die politik uns vorgibt nach
den maßgaben der wissenschaft aber jetzt
habe ich einfach so den überblick
verloren
dass ich keine lust mehr habe mich daran
zu halten zum beispiel schreibt sabine 3
oder brühe so ein durcheinander
unglaublich noch nie ein solches chaos
erlebt ich mache einfach was ich will
ich trag überall maske und halte überall
abstand lächerlich alles wie sehr
glauben sie werden sich die deutschen in
den nächsten wochen an welche regeln
halten und an welchen nicht
ja schwer zu sagen aber genau das was
die damals eben sagte ist das was ich
befürchte wenn das dann dazu führt dass
die leute meinetwegen überall maske
tragen ja meinetwegen aber das ist
natürlich auch eigentlich nicht der
richtige weg mir wäre recht wir würden
ruhig und besondere über aufklären und
aus meiner sicht muss diese aufklärung
ganz stark verkürzt mehr ist das bewusst
ganz stark für großes heißen das virus
ist da wir kriegen das auch nicht mehr
weg auch nicht über die nächsten jahre
wir werden uns an die maske für viele
monate gewöhnen müssen im stoff kann
helfen vielleicht aber auch nicht das
wissen wir noch nicht wir werden uns
daran gewöhnen wir werden das auch
meistern können aber wir müssen das tun
was der verbreitung des virus
entgegensteht und das heißt abstand
wahren maske tragen jedenfalls in
geschlossenen räumen handhygiene gehört
ebenfalls dazu und wenn wir das tun dann
werden wir infektionen nicht wirklich
komplett reduzieren können die werden
erst mal weiter ansteigen haben wir
können vielleicht verhindern dass sehr
viele menschen daran sterben
das muss unser ziel sein und wenn wir
uns darauf einigen könnten also was die
medizin geben vorgibt dann
glaube ich hätten wir viel gewonnen und
die leute würden dann auch wieder mit
gehen sagt der arzt und
medizinjournalist doktor christoph
specht vielen herzlichen dank für das
gespräch und die einordnungen nach
düsseldorf vielen dank an die user für
die regen kommentare und fragen und
vielen dank fürs zuschauen machen sie es
gut ist